For so many people now, it's not a theoretical thing. It's here, this new virus. And they're having to deal with that fact. Lots of people are trying to do the right thing.
对现在这么多人来说，这不再是理论上的事情了。它就在这里，这种新病毒。他们不得不面对这个事实。许多人都在试图做正确的事情。
But it's not so clear what the right thing is-- like Luis, who works in construction in Long Island. When he got tested and learned he had coronavirus, he went back to where he was living. He shared a house with several other migrants. He's an asylum seeker, here from Central America.
但什么是正确的事情并不那么明确——就像在长岛从事建筑工作的路易斯（Luis）。当他接受检测并得知自己感染了冠状病毒后，他回到了住处。他和另外几名移民合租一栋房子。他是一名来自中美洲的寻求庇护者。
And he immediately told his landlady because she's pregnant. He didn't want to put her or anybody at risk. She said he had to leave. So he decided to isolate in the only place he had-- his car.
他立即告诉了他的女房东，因为她怀孕了。他不想让她或任何人处于危险之中。她说他必须离开。所以他决定在唯一的容身之处——他的车里进行隔离。
He parked outside of a 7-Eleven. He didn't even want to go inside to get water because he didn't want to infect anybody. This is a voicemail message he left for the woman handling his immigration case.
他把车停在一家 7-Eleven 便利店外。他甚至不想进去买水，因为他不想传染给任何人。这是他给负责他移民案件的女士留下的语音留言。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
At this moment, I feel like I don't know what to do.
此时此刻，我觉得我不知道该怎么办。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
I've isolated in my car because I don't want to contaminate more people.
我在车里进行了自我隔离，因为我不想传染更多的人。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
I don't want people to go through what I'm going through.
我不希望人们经历我正在经历的事情。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
It hurts to tell the truth. It hurts.
说出真相令人痛苦。真的非常痛苦。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
You have no idea how much. He says, I haven't left my car. I've been cooped up here. If I didn't have a conscience, I'd be out there. But no, I don't have that kind of heart.
你无法想象有多痛苦。他说，我没有离开过我的车。我一直闷在这里。如果我没有良心，我就出去溜达了。但没有，我没有那种铁石心肠。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Zora heard this message, and she also tried to do the right thing. She found him housing to ride out the illness. Among other things, an epidemic, a plague, a contagion is a time that we're tested. And we rise to the occasion, or we don't, or we can't.
佐拉（Zora）听到了这条信息，她也试图做正确的事。她为他找到了一个度过疾病的住所。在其他事情中，流行病、瘟疫、传染病正是考验我们的时刻。我们要么挺身而出，要么做不到，要么无能为力。
Anthony Almojera very much wants his team to rise to the occasion. He's the vice president of local 3621 of the EMS Officers Union in New York City. EMS, emergency medical services-- it's part of the fire department.
安东尼·阿尔莫杰拉（Anthony Almojera）非常希望他的团队能够挺身而出。他是纽约市急救人员工会 3621 分会的副主席。EMS，即紧急医疗服务，是消防部门的一部分。
His job title is lieutenant paramedic. And besides the stuff he does for the union, he manages a crew of 50 EMS workers. Even before the coronavirus outbreak, they were short hundreds of EMS workers in the city. So they were overworked before. And it's even more so now.
他的职位是急救医务中尉。除了工会工作外，他还管理着一个 50 人的急救人员团队。甚至在冠状病毒爆发之前，该市就缺少数百名急救人员。所以他们之前就已经工作过度了。而现在情况更是如此。
Like this past Tuesday, Anthony worked a 16 hour shift at a station in Brooklyn, watching 911 calls come in. He talked to my co-worker Miki Meek. A typical day before the coronavirus outbreak was around 4,000 calls. This past week saw the first big spike.
就像上周二，安东尼在布鲁克林的车站值了 16 小时的班，看着 911 报警电话不断打入。他与我的同事米奇·米克（Miki Meek）进行了交谈。冠状病毒爆发前，典型的一天大约有 4,000 个电话。上周出现了第一次大规模激增。
I worked last night at 1:00 in the morning-- after we had just clocked in, 6,500 plus calls at midnight. At 1:00 in the morning, there were still 274 jobs holding. That's 274 jobs in the system that, at the moment, don't have an ambulance to get to them.
我昨晚凌晨 1 点工作——我们刚打卡上班，午夜时分就有 6,500 多个电话。凌晨 1 点，仍有 274 个任务在等待处理。这意味着系统中有 274 个任务，此时此刻，没有救护车可以赶过去。
So these are people that have called 911, but--
所以这些人拨打了 911，但是——
Right.
没错。
--no one's been able to be dispatched.
——没有人能够被派遣过去。
Right.
没错。
And how does that make you feel, when you see that you have that many call still in the queue?
当你看到队列中还有这么多电话时，你感觉如何？
It's a little frightening because, you know, to have been many calls holding-- just to give you some perspective-- yesterday, it was 6,500 calls-- it was the most we've ever done.
这有点可怕，因为，你知道，有这么多电话在排队——给你一个参考——昨天有 6,500 个电话——这是我们有史以来处理过最多的。
Ever?
有史以来？
Ever, yeah, even including 9/11.
有史以来，是的，甚至包括 9/11 事件。
Later that morning, he was in an ambulance and went on a call near Coney Island. A man had phoned in about his wife. He came home and found her on the floor. Call type said fever, cardiac arrest, COVID case.
那天晚些时候，他在救护车上接到了康尼岛附近的一个求救电话。一名男子打电话询问他的妻子。他回家时发现她倒在地板上。呼叫类型显示为发烧、心脏骤停、新冠病例。
And the husband is outside. And they're both health care workers. The patient was somebody who worked in a nursing home, and the husband works in the hospital. And she was sent home Friday with fever and remained feverish throughout.
丈夫就在外面。他们俩都是医护人员。患者是在疗养院工作的，而丈夫在医院工作。她周五被送回家时有发烧症状，之后一直处于发烧状态。
So I'm sitting there, talking to the husband. And he stated to me, yesterday, he called where he works to say he wanted to stay home and take care of his wife. And they told him he couldn't because he's an essential employee, that the hospital is short staffed, and he needed to come in.
所以我坐在那里，和那个丈夫交谈。他说，昨天他给工作的地方打电话，说他想留在家照顾妻子。但他们告诉他不行，因为他是重要岗位员工，医院人手不足，他必须去上班。
And at the moment, he judged that his wife wasn't critical. You know, she was feverish and stuff. But OK, she'll make it through the night. Then he came home and found her dead.
当时，他判断妻子的病情并不危急。你知道，她只是发烧什么的。但他想，好吧，她会熬过这一夜的。结果他回到家发现她已经死了。
Found her dead, he's saying.
他说发现她死在家中。
[SIGH]
[叹气]
For 17 years, I've been going on these calls of cardiac arrests or other traumatic things. And it's never been an issue for me to go up to the family member when we can't do any more, and say, I'm sorry. And then I put my arm around the patient's family member. You know, I let them cry into my shoulder, I've hugged them, anything along those lines to provide a moment of empathy and sympathy.
17 年来，我一直处理这些心脏骤停或其他创伤事件的电话。当我们无能为力时，走到家属身边说“我很抱歉”，对我来说从来都不是问题。然后我会搂住患者家属。你知道，我让他们靠在我的肩膀上哭泣，我拥抱过他们，任何类似的动作都能给予一点同情和安慰。
Yesterday, when I went outside because he happened to be outside, and I saw this man's grief in his face, and I saw him just break down and how he felt guilty about not being there, and I had to stay six feet away--
昨天，当我走到外面，因为他正好在外面，我看到这个男人的脸上充满了悲伤，看到他彻底崩溃，感到没能在那里的内疚，但我必须保持六英尺的距离——
Hmm.
嗯。
I couldn't kneel next to him like I have with other patients in the past. I couldn't put my arm around him because I'm concerned about my health because there's a high potentiality that he has it as well. And I just watched him. And it's the first time, in 17 years, that I actually got back in the truck and I cried.
我不能像过去对待其他病人那样跪在他身边。我不能搂住他，因为我担心自己的健康，因为他很有可能也感染了。我只是看着他。这是 17 年来第一次，我回到车里后哭了。
I'm sorry, Anthony.
对不起，安东尼。
No-- thank you.
不——谢谢你。
[DING]
[叮]
It's-- I'm sorry again.
那是——再次抱歉。
No, what's--
不，是什么——
That was the crew members. Yeah, I have about 60 messages that are unopened at the moment. Anthony, I tested positive. What do I do? Anthony, my wife tested positive. What do I do? They're all in that general nature.
那是我的队员。是的，我现在有大约 60 条未读信息。安东尼，我检测呈阳性，我该怎么办？安东尼，我妻子检测呈阳性，我该怎么办？它们基本都是这种性质的。
He's worried. How many of his crew won't be available soon? Going by numbers he's seen in other places, he figures half of them will end up quarantined.
他很担心。他的团队里有多少人很快就无法工作了？根据他在其他地方看到的数据，他估计他们中有一半人最终会被隔离。
Right now, in Anthony's crew of 50, six people are already out. The entire crew, all 50 of them, have been exposed to somebody with COVID-19 at this point. In the past, the policy for New York Fire Department EMS workers was, when you're exposed to a contagious virus like that, you weren't supposed to come to work.
目前，在安东尼的 50 人团队中，已经有 6 人无法工作。整个 50 人的团队目前都已经接触过 COVID-19 患者。过去，纽约消防局 EMS 员工的政策是，当你接触到这种传染性病毒时，就不应该去上班。
But the policy changed about a week and a half ago. Now you stay home only if you're actually showing symptoms. Anthony thinks it's because the city is so desperate for EMS workers right now.
但政策在大约一周半前改变了。现在，只有当你真正表现出症状时，你才留在家中。安东尼认为这是因为该市目前太急需急救人员了。
So if they can squeeze another five or six days out of you before you become symptomatic, I think that's what their motivation is.
所以，如果他们能在你出现症状之前再压榨你五六天，我想这就是他们的动机。
It's not said explicitly. But the crews are short. They need workers. You guys are essential.
虽然没有明确说出来。但团队人手短缺。他们需要员工。你们是重要员工。
It feels we're expendable. Now, listen, I don't believe that chief of EMS feels we are expendable. I don't want to put that on her.
感觉我们是可有可无的。听着，我不相信急救部门的主管认为我们是可有可无的。我不想把这一点归咎于她。
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
But it feels, overall, by the department and the city that we're just going to keep putting you out there because we don't have any other options, because we didn't properly prepare for this.
但从部门和城市的整体来看，感觉我们只是会被不断地派出去，因为他们别无选择，因为我们没有为此做好充分准备。
Spokesperson for the fire department told us that EMS workers are expected to show up if they've been exposed to the virus because at this point in New York, all EMS personnel have likely been exposed to the virus. Right now, EMS workers don't even have a way to get tested to see if they have the virus, just like the rest of us. And Anthony estimates they're going to run out of N95 masks in less than a week, this coming Friday, April 3.
消防部门发言人告诉我们，急救人员如果接触过病毒，仍被要求上班，因为在纽约目前的阶段，所有急救人员都可能已经接触过病毒。现在，急救人员甚至没有检测途径来确认自己是否感染，就像我们其他人一样。安东尼估计，他们的 N95 口罩在不到一周内就会用完，即即将到来的 4 月 3 日星期五。
What are you telling your workers right now?
你现在对你的员工说了些什么？
Well, the tough thing about this is we all signed up for this, you know? In a pandemic, that is EMS' time to shine, right? Treating viruses is what we do all day long. You name it, you know, HIV, hepatitis, meningitis. This is what we do.
关于这一点，最困难的是我们都签了这个协议，你知道吗？在流行病中，这是 EMS 大显身手的时刻，对吧？治疗病毒是我们整天都在做的事情。你说得出的，你知道，艾滋病、肝炎、脑膜炎。这就是我们所做的。
But in order to do it effectively, we have to believe that when we're out there with the potential of dying, getting hurt or seriously ill, that if something happens to us, we're going to be taken care of. And the consensus among the membership is that's not going to happen.
但为了有效地做到这一点，我们必须相信，当我们面临死亡、受伤或严重疾病的风险在外工作时，如果发生什么事，我们会得到照顾。而大家一致认为这不会发生。
The feeling is we're not going to be taken care of.
这种感觉就是我们不会得到照顾。
Yes.
是的。
What do you think the next couple weeks are going to be like?
你认为接下来的几周会是什么样子？
Oh, we're not even to the halfway point here. You know how they keep talking about flattening the curve?
哦，我们还没到一半呢。你知道他们一直说的“拉平曲线”吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
We're on the upward tick of that curve still.
我们仍处于那条曲线的上升期。
Do you have any workers who are wanting to quit?
有没有员工想要辞职？
No, I haven't had any workers that wanted to quit. I have not heard that.
没有，我没有听说有员工想要辞职。我还没听说过。
Because, like, the virus is here now. It's testing us, all of us, EMS workers, and doctors, and nurses, who are now risking their lives, but also delivery people, postal workers, politicians, those of us who are suddenly out of work, parents who have no talent for homeschooling at all, even those of us who are just on lockdown, worried for older relatives.
因为，病毒现在就在这里。它正在考验我们所有人——急救人员、医生、护士，他们现在冒着生命危险，还有快递员、邮政工人、政客、那些突然失业的人、那些根本没有居家教育天赋的父母，甚至是我们这些仅仅处于封锁状态、担心年长亲人的人。
We're all being tested. So today in our program, we're going to hear from people who are right in the middle of it now, being tested in pretty extreme ways. Plus, before the hour's out, a call from the future from somebody in China who's kind of on the other side of this thing. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们都在接受考验。所以今天在我们的节目中，我们将听到那些正处于困境中心、正以相当极端的方式接受考验的人们的心声。此外，节目结束前，还会有一个来自未来的电话，来自中国，那里的人正处于这场灾难的另一面。来自芝加哥 WBEZ，这是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
[MUSIC - "STAY YOUR ASS INDOORS" BY MNEK]
[音乐 - MNEK 的《STAY YOUR ASS INDOORS》]
Throughout this episode, we're featuring original songs that we heard on Instagram created by the British musician and producer MNEK while he's been home alone and social distancing. He's jokingly calling these songs his Corona EP, and they are all him, no backing band, looping his own voice. The songs are part PSA, part pure pop, just a man bringing some light in a dark moment. Now, we turn to Act One.
在本集节目中，我们将播出我们在 Instagram 上听到的原创歌曲，这些歌曲是由英国音乐家兼制作人 MNEK 在独自在家保持社交距离时创作的。他开玩笑地称这些歌曲为他的“新冠 EP”，而且全都是他一个人录制的，没有伴奏乐队，循环播放他自己的声音。这些歌曲既是公共服务广告，又是纯粹的流行乐，只是一个在黑暗时刻带来一丝光明的人。现在，进入第一幕。
Act One, The Inside Game-- OK, so this virus is out there. And so many of us are scared to get it and wonder what would happen if we did get it. And honestly, for all the coverage of the illness, we have not heard the people that it's happened to talk at length about that experience very much.
第一幕，室内游戏——好吧，这种病毒就在外面。我们很多人都害怕感染它，想知道如果感染了会怎样。老实说，尽管对这种疾病有大量的报道，但我们很少听到感染者详细谈论那段经历。
One thing that came up here is-- we've all talked about this-- is what is going on in the homes where both parents get the virus, like how do they manage? And just coincidentally, one of our co-workers, Ben Calhoun, has been worried about his brother-in-law, Elia Einhorn, and Elia's wife, Amy, who are in that exact situation. They were among the first wave of COVID-19 patients in New York City.
这里出现的一件事是——我们都谈论过这个问题——那些父母双方都感染病毒的家庭现在是什么情况，他们是如何应对的？巧合的是，我们的一位同事本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）一直很担心他的姐夫埃利亚·艾因霍恩（Elia Einhorn）和埃利亚的妻子艾米（Amy），他们正处于那种境地。他们是纽约市第一批 COVID-19 患者。
Their daughter, whose name is Conwy, is just a toddler. So she is in that period of parenting when a kid needs constant vigilance. Ben recorded a call with them. Amy, who got sick first, was too sick to actually get out of bed.
他们的女儿，名叫康威（Conwy），还是个蹒跚学步的孩子。所以她正处于父母需要时刻保持警惕的养育阶段。本记录了与他们的通话。艾米最先患病，病情太重，无法下床。
Elia could drag himself around. But it was pretty rough going. He was sicker than he had ever been in his life, he said. One other detail-- Elia has a history of asthma, so he's at elevated risk. He'd also developed GI symptoms, throwing up, a possible warning sign that a COVID patient is in more danger.
埃利亚可以勉强走动。但情况相当糟糕。他说这是他一生中最严重的疾病。还有一个细节——埃利亚有哮喘病史，所以他属于高危人群。他还出现了胃肠道症状，呕吐，这可能是新冠患者面临更大危险的警告信号。
All this is playing out in a 500 square foot New York City apartment. So picture like three rooms and a bathroom. Ben called them in the afternoon. Elia had just gotten Conwy to nap, so you'll hear Elia trying to keep his voice down, trying not to wake her.
所有这一切都发生在一个 500 平方英尺的纽约公寓里。所以想象一下，就像三个房间和一个浴室。本在下午给他们打了电话。埃利亚刚把康威哄睡着，所以你会听到埃利亚尽量压低声音，不吵醒她。
What is just like the logistics of your situation in the apartment right now? Like where are you? And where is Amy? And how much are you able to either be around each other or not be around each other, or?
你现在的公寓情况大概是什么样的物流安排？你和艾米都在哪里？你们能有多少时间在一起或不能在一起？
I haven't seen Amy in like a week. Amy has just been in our room the whole time. So since there's one bathroom, she comes out to use the bathroom. And otherwise, like, I just don't see her.
我大概有一个星期没见过艾米了。艾米一直待在我们的房间里。因为只有一个浴室，她出来用一下。除此之外，就像我根本见不到她一样。
And we usually talk for like one or two minutes. But yeah, Amy is just in our room. And she's really, really sick. Her fever goes up and down and up and down. And just when we think it's gone, it comes back worse, and it's--
我们通常谈话也就一两分钟。但是的，艾米就待在我们的房间里。她病得很重。她的发烧反反复复。刚以为退烧了，又变严重了，而且——
But she's just 100% like locked in the room?
但她就是 100% 被锁在房间里吗？
Yeah, locked in the room. Literally, I told her lock the door so Conwy can't come in.
是的，锁在房间里。我甚至告诉她锁上门，这样康威就进不来了。
But you got to-- you got Conwy down, though.
但是你还得——你哄睡了康威，是吗？
She's asleep. She's asleep. I am going to-- I just saw Amy. I get to see her like three times a day for two minutes. And I said to her, we are going to have to do such a strict regimen to get this kid back to normal life after this because I am like-- you know, I'm trying to keep her life as normal as possible.
她睡着了，她睡着了。我打算——我刚看到艾米。我每天大概能见她三次，每次两分钟。我对她说，我们必须制定非常严格的制度，在这之后让孩子恢复正常生活，因为我——你知道，我尽量让她的生活尽可能正常。
So because she already can't see Amy, she can't go outside-- so I am just like-- I've become the biggest fucking pushover. I said to Amy, she had like a tasting menu before bed.
所以因为她已经见不到艾米，也出不去——所以我简直变成了最大的软蛋。我对艾米说，她睡觉前简直像在享受一份品鉴菜单。
We usually let her have a little snack if she wants it. She's adding things, having me get up and go to the kitchen and get more stuff. And I, like, can hardly handle getting up to go get her something. It's just like, oh, dude.
我们通常让她吃点小零食，如果她想吃的话。她一直在加东西，让我起床去厨房拿更多。而我，几乎无法支撑自己起床去给她拿东西。简直是，噢，老兄。
So she must have had bites of like seven snacks. And it's ridiculous. But I just wanted her to--
所以她一定吃了大概七份零食。这很荒谬。但我只是想让她——
And I can imagine that, as a parent, you're just like-- you're having all these needs that are unmet right now. And right now, you're having a need that I can meet. So let me just throw whatever I can in there.
我能想象作为父母，你就是——你现在有很多未被满足的需求。而现在，你有一个我可以满足的需求。所以让我尽可能地满足她吧。
Exactly, exactly. I looked-- I looked at us. We were reading one of those Mo Willems books, you know that like--
没错，没错。我看着——看着我们。我们正在读那些莫·威廉姆斯（Mo Willems）的书，你知道那个——
Yeah, like Piggy and the Elephant.
是的，比如《小猪和小象》。
Yeah, we were reading-- I don't know why. But she wanted to read the baby one.
对，我们正在读——我不知道为什么。但她想读那本关于小宝宝的。
And there's two pages that are mirrors. And I looked at us, and I was like, we look so blazed. We look like college freshmen who just discovered weed and smoked half an ounce, you know.
书里有两页是镜子。我看着我们，心想，我们看起来太颓废了。我们看起来像那种刚发现大麻并抽了半盎司的大学新生，你知道吧。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Me and the two and a half year old look terrible. And I'm wearing my mask, you know, because there's this theory about the viral load getting bigger, you know I mean? With more exposure.
我和两岁半的孩子看起来糟透了。我戴着口罩，你知道吗，因为有一种理论说病毒载量会变大，你懂我的意思吗？随着接触次数增加。
So just to give you sort of a scene report here, it looks like-- think about a normal Brooklyn-sized apartment. It looks like there was 50 toddlers who had an unsupervised birthday party here. So like, from my vantage point on the couch, I'm looking out.
那么给你做一个现场报告，看起来就像——想想一个普通的布鲁克林大小的公寓。看起来就像有 50 个蹒跚学步的孩子在这里开了个无人看管的生日派对。所以，从我在沙发上的位置看过去。
The first layer is like a peg's game, where you push buttons into colors. The second layer is all these 3x2 foot huge Paw Patrol pages to color. The next level is a farm that seems to have exploded. The next level are all the Play-Dohs strewn around the ground because I just can't pick it up.
第一层是类似拼图游戏，把按钮按进颜色里。第二层是所有这些 3x2 英尺巨大的汪汪队（Paw Patrol）涂色纸。下一层是一个看起来好像爆炸了的农场。再下一层是散落在地上的所有橡皮泥，因为我实在捡不动了。
Do you have all your logistics covered like groceries? How you doing groceries? How are you like-- I don't know, like laundry.
你们的物流，比如杂货，都处理好了吗？杂货怎么买？你们怎么——我不知道，比如洗衣服。
Laundry has been a problem. I'm waiting for Amy to get better because we have to wash it in the bathtub. And I just can't physically do it right now. I can't stress to you how tired I am. I'm like--
洗衣服一直是个问题。我在等艾米好起来，因为我们必须在浴缸里洗。但我现在身体上真的做不到。我无法向你强调我有多累。我简直——
You're just too tired.
你只是太累了。
I'm just too tired, man. I can't sit up that long. And so I'm waiting for Amy to either get better so that she can watch Conwy and I can take longer and do it slowly-- or because, by the end of the day, when Conwy goes to sleep, I'm like fried, totally fried. I can't even stand up.
我就是太累了，伙计。我无法坐太久。所以我等着艾米好起来，要么她可以照顾康威，我就可以慢一点、慢慢做——或者因为，到了一天结束，康威睡着时，我就像炸了一样，完全炸了。我甚至站不起来。
Because you're the only person doing Conwy, right? You're like--
因为只有你一个人在照顾康威，对吧？你就像——
Oh, yeah, 100%. Yeah, Amy hasn't seen her in a week. It's like I'm just with her like now 24/7.
哦，是的，100%。是的，艾米一个星期没见她了。现在就像我 24 小时全天候地和她待在一起。
Do you feel like you've-- I feel like, if I were you, I would keep waiting to feel, like, bottomed out-- be like, is this-- is this the bottom? Is this the bottom?
你有没有觉得你一直在等那种触底的感觉——就像在想，这是不是底了？这是不是底了？
Yeah, man.
是的，伙计。
Just like waiting for that upswing, you know.
就像在等那种回升，你知道。
I keep waiting for it. And I think it comes. I thought it came like four times. And then like, today, I'm the most tired I've been the whole time. So I just don't know.
我一直等着它。我想它快来了。我以为它出现了四次。然后就像今天，是我整个期间最累的一天。所以我真的不知道。
And it's like, on the one hand, I mean, we have food. We have water. We have electricity. I mean, we have everything we need.
一方面，我的意思是，我们有食物。我们有水。我们有电。我的意思是，我们有需要的一切。
If this is all that ever happens, it'll be a triumph. It seriously will if this is all that happens. It's just the scariest part is, is it going to go into our lungs, you know?
如果这就是所能发生的一切，那将是一个胜利。如果这就是全部后果，那真的是个胜利。最可怕的是，它会进入我们的肺部吗，你知道？
Yeah.
是的。
Right when I start to feel better, I think, you know there's these-- it sort of shows it's these ground glass sort of deposits in people's lungs. And I've started thinking of it as like your lungs turning to glass.
就在我开始感觉好一点的时候，我想，你知道有这些——它有点显示出这是一种在人的肺部形成的磨玻璃状沉积物。我开始认为这就像你的肺变成了玻璃。
And I keep reading these stories out of Wuhan about these young physicians that are like my age, I mean, relatively young physicians that are dying from this. And I had to stop reading them because it's like, I just can't keep reading about people's lungs metaphorically turning to glass. And it's just making me worry too much that it's going to happen to our family.
我一直读着武汉那些像我这个年纪的年轻医生的故事，我的意思是，相对年轻的医生死于这种病。我不得不停止阅读，因为我简直无法再读关于人们的肺部隐喻性地变成玻璃的故事。这只是让我太担心它会发生在我们家人身上。
It's so scary to not be able to protect your family against this insidious element of it. And that's why I-- that's why I emailed you guys that stuff. I don't know if anything's going to happen. And if it does happen, it's going to happen so quick.
无法保护家人免受这种阴险因素的伤害真是太可怕了。这就是为什么我——这就是为什么我给你们发了那些邮件。我不知道会不会发生什么。如果发生了，它会发生得非常快。
I don't have time to deal with anything. I don't have time to deal with getting my affairs in order, you know. So I emailed you and Katherine very perfunctory, like here's-- how to-- what me and Amy want, here's our financial stuff. Here's like-- because I just have no fucking clue.
我没时间处理任何事情。我没时间处理安排我的后事，你知道。所以我给你们和凯瑟琳发了非常简短的邮件，比如这是——我想要什么——我和艾米想要什么，这是我们的财务状况。这是因为我简直他妈的毫无头绪。
And that's the worst part. If we could be guaranteed that that wasn't going to happen-- this would just be uncomfortable and fine. We can laugh about it in a different way. But it's the fear that, at any second, one of us could just take really ill and maybe worse.
那是这其中最糟糕的部分。如果我们能确保这种情况不会发生——这只是一场不适，也没事。我们可以以不同的方式谈笑风生。但那种恐惧是，任何一秒，我们中的一个可能就会病得很重，甚至更糟。
We're so worried about you.
我们太为你担心了。
Yeah.
是啊。
How do you think that Conwy's doing?
你觉得康威现在怎么样？
Physically, she's doing fine. But she's showing all of these behaviors about being upset. And she's actively talking about it. Now, like every bed time, she wants me to tell her stories about everybody getting sick, me getting sick, her getting sick, Amy getting sick, you getting sick, and Katherine, and your kids. Everyone in our family getting sick is now part of our story.
身体上，她很好。但她表现出所有这些心烦意乱的行为。她现在很主动地谈论它。现在，每次睡觉前，她都想让我给她讲关于每个人都生病的故事，我生病了，她生病了，艾米生病了，你生病了，还有凯瑟琳，你的孩子。我们家里的每个人都生病了，现在成了我们故事的一部分。
Yeah--
是的——
We're calling it--
我们在称它为——
--she's just trying to process it.
——她只是在尝试处理它。
--is what we're playing. Yeah, exactly. We tell her it's the inside game. Everybody's playing the inside game right now. And soon, it's going to end.
——这就是我们要玩的。是的，没错。我们告诉她这是“室内游戏”。每个人现在都在玩室内游戏。很快，它就会结束。
But for now, this is what's happening. And these are the rules of the inside game. But she keeps saying like, daddy, I'm so tired. I'm so tired.
但现在，这就是正在发生的事情。这就是室内游戏的规则。但她一直说，爸爸，我好累。我好累。
And we're snuggling a lot. The pediatrician even said, look, if you both get tested positive, you can both just come out. And you can just take off your mask and be around Conwy.
我们经常依偎在一起。儿科医生甚至说，听着，如果你们俩都检测呈阳性，你们俩就可以一起出来。你们可以脱下口罩，和康威在一起。
But with all this research about the viral load buildup, we've had an infectious disease doctor that we've been talking to that said, you know, don't do that. You can snuggle her if you need to because she's a toddler. You can't control that. But like, as little as possible, so I try to put her between my legs or have my foot on her just to touch her a little bit, you know.
但考虑到关于病毒载量积累的所有研究，我们一直在咨询的一位传染病医生说，你知道，别那么做。如果需要，你可以拥抱她，因为她是个蹒跚学步的孩子。你控制不了那个。但要尽可能少，所以我试着把她放在我双腿之间或者把我的脚放在她身上，只是为了稍微触碰她一下，你知道。
But it's been sad. I mean, she said to me like, I so sad. I so sad. None of my friends want to come to my house.
但这很令人悲伤。我的意思是，她对我说了像，我好伤心。我好伤心。我的朋友们都不想来我家。
[CRIES]
[哭泣]
Oh.
噢。
Aw, man.
唉，伙计。
That's hard.
真难过。
Like, everything that she draws, she's like, this is for my friends. Or I made this for my mommy. This is for mommy.
就像，她画的所有东西，她都会说，这是给我朋友的。或者我这是为我妈妈做的。这是给妈妈的。
On the one hand, she's doing fine. And on the other hand, she's really feeling her age equivalent of like really lonely and cut off. She keeps talking to me about how sick Amy is. And I tell her like, you know, mom is sick. But mom's getting better.
一方面，她表现得很好。另一方面，她真的感到了与她年龄相当的孤独和被隔绝。她一直跟我谈论艾米病得有多重。我告诉她，你知道，妈妈生病了。但妈妈正在好转。
And I didn't even tell her I was sick, but she somehow figured it out. And I don't know if it's the mask, or what. So she says, daddy's sick. And I said, daddy's a little bit sick, but he's OK.
我甚至没告诉她我生病了，但她不知怎么就发现了。我不知道是因为口罩，还是其他什么原因。所以她说，爸爸生病了。我说，爸爸有点生病，但他没事。
I mean, I feel traumatic, feeling so upset about it. But again, it's like-- like, are these the last conversations that I'm ever going to have with her?
我的意思是，我觉得很痛苦，因为这感到非常难过。但再说一次，就像——这些是我和她最后谈话的机会吗？
Oh, Els--
噢，埃尔斯——
Oh, man. You're getting the ugly cry.
噢，伙计。你快要哭得丑死了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Oh, dude.
噢，伙计。
You're getting the ugly cry. I've only let myself cry about it a little bit.
你快要哭得丑死了。我只允许自己为它哭了一点点。
I wish I could do something for you guys.
我真希望能为你们做点什么。
Oh. You're a regular Barbara Walters, Ben. You're getting it out of me.
噢。你真是个标准的芭芭拉·沃尔特斯（Barbara Walters），本。你把我的心声都掏出来了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Should we have the kids FaceTime tonight? Would that-- would that be helpful?
我们要不要让孩子们今晚 FaceTime？那样——那样会有帮助吗？
Yeah, that would be, just for her and for me to just sit down for a minute, honestly. It's like one of the only times I can rest when she's awake.
是的，那会很有用，只是为了她，也为了我能坐下休息一会，老实说。这真的是她醒着时我唯一能休息的时候。
We can do more of that, too, like if the kids can keep her occupied on FaceTime.
我们可以做更多那样的事，比如如果孩子们能在 FaceTime 上分散她的注意力。
Oh, man. Honestly, you guys are great.
噢，伙计。老实说，你们太棒了。
[CRYING]
[哭泣]
Now she's waking up. That's the peril of making any noise in this environment. But hopefully, she'll go back to sleep. You guys have been amazing. Just FaceTiming with your kids has been amazing. Yeah, we're just going to have to ride it the fuck out.
现在她醒了。这就是在这个环境中发出任何声音的代价。但希望她能回去睡觉。你们太棒了。光是和你们的孩子 FaceTime 就太棒了。是的，我们只能硬撑下去了。
Elia Einhorn with Ben Calhoun, who's a producer on our show. That was recorded a little over a week ago. At this point today, Amy is much better. She's actually up and around.
埃利亚·艾因霍恩与我们节目的制作人本·卡尔霍恩的对话。那是大约一周前录制的。今天此时此刻，艾米的情况好多了。她实际上已经能下床走动了。
Elia got a lot worse after that call. But now he's also feeling better. Conwy is presumed to have had a mild case of the virus. She's doing fine.
埃利亚在那次通话后病情严重了很多。但现在他也感觉好多了。康威被认为患有轻度病毒感染。她很好。
[MUSIC - "QUARANTINE" BY MNEK]
[音乐 - MNEK 的《QUARANTINE》]
Act Two, The View From the Park-- so one of the producers here at our show, Emanuele Berry, got to know reporter Jiayang Fan back when were doing our Hong Kong show this past fall. Jiayang's a staff writer at The New Yorker. Emanuele and she have stayed in touch since then. Emanuele was the editor for a story that Jiayang did here a few weeks ago.
第二幕，公园里的风景——我们节目的制作人之一埃曼努埃尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry），在去年秋天我们制作香港节目时结识了记者贾阳·范（Jiayang Fan）。贾阳是《纽约客》的特约撰稿人。埃曼努埃尔和她从那时起一直保持联系。埃曼努埃尔是贾阳几周前在这里做的一个故事的编辑。
Jiayang has a mom who is in a medical facility in New York City. Jiayang tweets about her all the time. And right now, Jiayang's in the situation that a lot of us are in, worried for our parents, but a much more extreme version of that than most of us are dealing with. Like already, so much has happened with her mom. Emanuele checked in with her.
贾阳的母亲在纽约市的一家医疗机构。贾阳经常在推特上发关于她的内容。现在，贾阳正处于我们许多人所处的境地，担心我们的父母，但比我们大多数人处理的情况要极端得多。比如，她母亲身上已经发生了太多事情。埃曼努埃尔联系了她。
How are you?
你好吗？
I am trying to hang in there, I guess, is the most optimistic way of putting it.
我在努力坚持，我想，这是最乐观的说法。
Yeah, yeah. I mean, I follow you on Twitter. I see that you tweet a lot about your mom. But I don't actually exactly know what your mother's ailment is. I just know she's hospitalized. Can you-- what's going on there?
是的，是的。我的意思是，我在推特上关注你。我看到你经常发关于你母亲的推文。但我并不确切知道你母亲的疾病是什么。我只知道她住院了。你能——那里发生了什么？
My mother doesn't have control of any part of her body at this point, except for her eyeballs, the movement of her eyeballs. So she is completely cognitively intact and as sharp as she ever has been. But she's imprisoned in a body that refuses to cooperate in any way.
我母亲目前无法控制身体的任何部位，除了她的眼球，眼球的转动。所以她在认知上完全正常，和以往一样敏锐。但她被囚禁在一个拒绝以任何方式合作的身体里。
She hasn't left her bed, her hospital bed, except to go to the ICU for the last six years. The only time she's ever seen any sliver of the sky is in those few minutes when paramedics push her from the hospital entrance into an ambulance. So when I visit her, I feel like I'm bringing the world to her.
除了去 ICU，她过去六年来没有离开过她的床，她的病床。她唯一一次看到天空碎片的时候，是在救护人员把她从医院入口推进救护车的那几分钟。所以当我去看她时，我觉得我把整个世界带给了她。
Her mother, Yao Li, has ALS. She's lived in a facility for the past six years. She always has an aid by her side. Jiayang's apartment is just a three minute walk away.
她的母亲姚莉（Yao Li）患有渐冻症（ALS）。她在过去六年里一直住在一个设施里。她身边总有一名护理人员。贾阳的公寓离那只有三分钟的步行路程。
She visits every day, sometimes twice a day, unless she's traveling for work. When Jiayang visits, they talk. Well, mostly Jiayang talks. Yao Li spells things out using her eyes and an alphabet chart. It's slow. But that doesn't stop Yao Li from expressing herself.
她每天都去探望，有时一天两次，除非她因工作出差。当贾阳去探望时，他们交谈。好吧，主要是贾阳在说。姚莉用她的眼睛和字母表拼写东西。这很慢。但这并没有阻止姚莉表达自己。
Sometimes she tries to tell me bawdy jokes over the alphabet chart that she spells with her eyes. And it'll take me an hour. And I'll think that she's requesting--
有时她试着通过字母表告诉我一些下流的笑话，她用眼睛拼写出来。这会花掉我一个小时。我会以为她在要求——
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
--a medication or that some part of her-- like she'll mention butt, and I'll be like, oh, is her butt hurting? You know, what-- do you have an infection? And it's she's trying to tell me a butt joke. So that's--
——药物，或者她身体的某一部分——比如她会提到臀部，我会说，哦，是她的臀部在痛吗？你知道，什么——你有感染吗？结果她是在试着给我讲一个臀部笑话。所以这就是——
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
So-- so that gives you a little bit of a sense of my mom. She is someone who [LAUGHS] who is relentlessly truthful. Whenever a piece comes out of mine, her first question is, read me all the negative tweets about it. What is the criticism like? What are your trolls sayings?
所以——这让你对我妈妈有个了解。她是一个（笑声）无情地诚实的人。每当我的一篇文章发表，她的第一个问题就是，给我读读所有关于它的负面推文。批评是什么样的？你的喷子们是怎么说的？
And I know that sounds absurd and funny. But I think that comes from an immigrant's survival mentality. She wants to know what I need to prepare myself for in order to survive.
我知道这听起来很荒谬和有趣。但我认为这来自于移民的生存心态。她想知道我需要为生存做些什么准备。
So what happened last week? Take me through what happened last week.
那么上周发生了什么？带我回顾一下上周发生的事情。
Remember, my mother is always-- in the best of times, my mother is a mild infection away from death, in the best of times. The doctors have told me, again and again, she will die of pneumonia. It's just a matter of time.
记住，我母亲总是——即使在最好的时候，我母亲距离死亡也仅一步之遥。医生一次又一次地告诉我，她会死于肺炎。这只是时间问题。
She's already on a respirator, a machine that breathes for her. There's not that much that can be done. So when I hear news about viruses entering nursing homes, every nerve in my body is on full alarm.
她已经在用呼吸机了，那是一种为她呼吸的机器。能做的并不多。所以当我听到有关病毒进入疗养院的消息时，我全身的每一根神经都处于全面警惕状态。
Jiayang once told me that her mother lives for her. But the reverse is also true. Jiayang lives for her mom. They're each other's only family, which means Jiayang is a very active family member at her mom's facility.
贾阳曾告诉我，她母亲是为了她而活。但反过来也一样。贾阳是为了她妈妈而活。她们是彼此唯一的家人，这意味着贾阳是她母亲所在机构里非常积极的家庭成员。
The staff knows her. They know how protective she is. So in early March, when she heard about the virus spreading in nursing homes, she called, said, hey, I know it's a stressful time. But could you ask doctors and nurses to wear gloves and masks before getting too close to my mom? She says she could hear the tone in her own voice, anxious and demanding.
工作人员认识她。他们知道她有多么保护她。所以在三月初，当她听说病毒在疗养院蔓延时，她打电话说，嘿，我知道现在是很紧张的时候。但能不能请医生和护士在靠近我妈妈之前戴上手套和口罩？她说她能听出自己声音中的语气，焦虑而苛刻。
This is not a tone I've ever taken with any member of my mom's facility for as long as she'd been there. But I was-- I was unnerved enough--
只要我妈妈在那里，我就从来没用这种语气和任何工作人员说过话。但我当时——但我被吓到了——
You were freaked out.
你吓坏了。
Yeah.
是的。
I was unnerved enough about what I was reading that I called first thing in the morning to say that. And I think the staff who picked up, was very annoyed with me and just said-- and basically said, I can't do that. Like, I can't-- I don't-- I can't tell other people here what to do.
我被我读到的东西吓坏了，所以一大早我就打电话说了那番话。我想接电话的工作人员对我非常恼火，只是说——基本上说，我做不到。就像，我不能——我不——我不能告诉这里的其他人该怎么做。
And then I think she thought she hung up. She didn't actually hang up. And she said, yeah, Yao Li's daughter just called. And she thinks that, like, we have to wear gloves and, you know, masks like around every patient at the hospital. And there was-- I heard laughter all around.
然后我觉得她以为她挂断了电话。她其实没挂。她说，是的，姚莉的女儿刚打了电话。她认为，我们必须在医院里的每个病人身边戴上手套和，你知道，口罩。然后我听到周围一片笑声。
And then, really, unfortunately, I heard her say-- I still, to this day, do not know who that staff member was. But she said, you know, and they're the ones who are Chinese.
然后，真的很不幸，我听到她说——直到今天，我仍然不知道那个工作人员是谁。但她说，你知道，而且她们还是中国人。
To be frank, I wasn't offended. I wasn't like, oh, my God. This is so racist. I was just worried. I was worried about having offended her. I was worried about offending people who are the first line of defense.
坦白说，我并没有被冒犯。我没有那种，哦，天哪。这太种族主义了。我只是担心。我担心冒犯了她。我担心冒犯那些处于第一道防线的人。
So she put her coat on over her pajamas and ran over to the facility. But when she got there, there were security guards up front and big signs. Jiayang was so flustered she doesn't actually remember exactly what the sign said.
于是她穿着睡衣披上外套，跑到了那家机构。但当她到达那里时，前面有保安和大牌子。贾阳太慌乱了，她其实不记得牌子上具体写了什么。
But the message was clear. She wasn't getting in to see her mom. How could she be sure her mom was OK if she couldn't see her?
但信息很明确。她进不去探望她妈妈。如果她见不到她，她怎么能确定她妈妈没事呢？
I became crazed. I was calling my best friend, who were telling me that I wasn't being a rational, functional person. I had a dream about moving my mother to a different planet. I know that sounds absurd.
我变得疯狂了。我给最好的朋友打电话，她们告诉我我不理智，不正常了。我做了一个梦，梦到把我妈妈转移到另一个星球。我知道这听起来很荒谬。
And it's my subconscious-- I mean, it's my unconscious. So I'm not totally responsible for it. But I think some part of me knew that there was no corner on earth that was safe.
这是我的潜意识——我的意思是，这是我的无意识。所以我对此并不完全负责。但我认为我的一部分知道地球上没有一个角落是安全的。
How would that even-- how would that even work with a move? She is on a feeding tube. She's on a ventilator. She's hooked up on so many different whirling machines. In the best of times, a move would be-- would require six people, not including the transport.
那种转移会怎么——怎么运作？她靠饲管维持。她戴着呼吸机。她连接着这么多台不同的旋转机器。在最好的时候，转移也需要六个人，还不算运输人员。
Talking to Jiayang, I noticed she couldn't help herself going down these thought spirals, far fetched ways to save her mom, all the things that could go wrong. And I think that's because she can't do anything, and she wants to badly. But there isn't a way out.
和贾阳交谈时，我注意到她无法控制自己陷入这些思维漩涡中，那些远得离谱的救妈妈的方法，所有可能出错的事情。我想这是因为她无能为力，而她又太想帮忙了。但没有出路。
Where could she possibly go? Not in my apartment, my tiny, almost studio-sized apartment would not be able to fit all the equipment that she needs. And I wouldn't be-- I would not be fit to care for her by myself.
她能去哪里？我的公寓不行，我狭小的、几乎是单间大小的公寓无法容纳她需要的所有设备。而且我自己也——我无法独自照顾她。
Then what other facility is safe? Like, what other facility in New York City is safe? What other facility in America is safe?
那么还有哪个设施是安全的？比如，纽约市还有哪个设施是安全的？美国还有哪个设施是安全的？
And so you're basically at a point where you're like there-- I can't-- there's nothing I can-- there's nothing I can do.
所以你基本上到了一个地步，你觉得——我不能——我做不了什么。
I'm basically at the point where my unconscious is dreaming up plants to take my mother to Mars. My mind goes to very strange places, where I think about being told that my mother's ventilator has to be-- that my mother's ventilator is better--
我基本上到了我的潜意识在梦想着带我母亲去火星的地步。我的思绪去了非常奇怪的地方，我想到被告知我母亲的呼吸机必须——我母亲的呼吸机更适合——
I'm sorry. It's hard for me to even come up the grammar for this because it's so hard. That my mother's ventilator could better serve someone who's younger and healthier.
对不起。我甚至很难组织语言，因为它太难了。我母亲的呼吸机可能更适合那些更年轻、更健康的人。
This hasn't happened. Nobody's suggested her mom give up her ventilator. But she can't stop thinking of the possibility of it.
这还没发生。没人建议她妈妈放弃呼吸机。但她无法停止思考这种可能性。
And then my mind goes down a rabbit hole. I start looking up surgeries where I could give up half my lung, maybe, so that this healthy person can still be saved because-- because it's about lungs filling with fluids, right? And I think, well, if I could save that other person, then my mother gets to keep her ventilator.
然后我的思绪钻进了牛角尖。我开始查找手术，我可以捐出一半肺，也许，这样这个健康的人就能被拯救，因为——因为这是关于肺部充满液体，对吧？我想，嗯，如果我能救那个人，那么我母亲就能保留她的呼吸机。
And your mind just spends hours in those rabbit holes, which are completely-- it's completely useless, right? Because it's not-- I mean, these are not my decisions. What I'm suggesting is probably totally insane and scientifically, medically impractical.
你的大脑只是花了几小时在那些牛角尖里，这完全是——这完全是无用的，对吧？因为这不是——我的意思是，这不是我的决定。我所建议的可能完全是疯狂的，在科学和医学上是不切实际的。
Jiayang did get a small bit of relief. She managed to get in for one last visit. That was two weeks ago.
贾阳确实得到了一点缓解。她设法进行了最后一次探望。那是两周前的事了。
What did you guys say to each other?
你们说了些什么？
Because I am her daughter, I'm her caregiver. I am her conduit to the world. I have a responsibility to soothe her panic, not to stoke it.
因为我是她的女儿，我是她的照顾者。我是她与世界沟通的管道。我有责任平复她的恐慌，而不是煽动它。
I said things to her that I think I would've wanted someone else to say to me, which is this is going to be OK. We will get through this. (VOICE CRACKING) I will see you again very soon. I don't know when, but it's going to be very soon. And we will get through this together. But they weren't words that I necessarily believed if I were to be totally honest.
我对她说了那些我觉得如果有人对我这么说会很想听的话，那就是一切都会好起来的。我们能挺过去的。（声音哽咽）我会很快再见到你的。我不知道是什么时候，但会很快。我们会一起挺过去的。但如果诚实地说，这些话连我自己都不太相信。
She talked with senior hospital staff. And they told her there's a significant chance that coronavirus will enter the facility, that she should be mentally prepared for what that means. Jiayang thought about staying with her mom, just never leaving that visit, becoming her mom's caretaker.
她和医院的高层人员谈过。他们告诉她，冠状病毒进入该设施的可能性很大，她应该在心理上做好这意味着什么的准备。贾阳想过留下来陪她妈妈，就在那次探望中永远不走，成为她妈妈的照顾者。
But her mother's longtime aide convinced Jiayang she'd be more help to her mom outside and promised that she would stay with Yao Li, as long as she could manage. At the time, they were hopeful it would only be a few weeks.
但她母亲的长年助理说服了贾阳，说她在外面对自己母亲更有帮助，并承诺只要她能撑得住，就会一直待在姚莉身边。当时，他们还希望能坚持几周。
(VOICE CRACKING) I mean, I doubt myself. I don't know if I made the right decision. I think that, if my mom is going to-- if she's not going to survive the illness, then I should be the one in there. And then, I mean-- and then my mind goes to dark places.
（声音哽咽）我的意思是，我质疑自己。我不知道我是否做出了正确的决定。我想，如果我妈妈要——如果她不能从这种疾病中幸存下来，那么我应该是在里面的人。然后，我的意思是——然后我的思绪去了阴暗的地方。
I think, well, who cares if I don't pay the rent? Who cares if just everything else goes into absolute madness? All I want to be is with my mom.
我想，嗯，谁在乎我不付房租？谁在乎其他一切是否陷入绝对的疯狂？我唯一想做的就是和我妈妈在一起。
Yeah, I mean, what do you think your mom would want you to do in this situation?
是的，我的意思是，你认为你妈妈在这种情况下会让你做什么？
It was-- it was really hard to leave her. She began crying, just hysterically crying, because I think she knew that, despite my assurances, that it would be a long time before I saw her again. And I think-- I think she would-- I think she would want me to stay safe. I think she would want me to find a way of coping through this crisis without succumbing to it, without being crushed by it.
离开她真的很难。她开始歇斯底里地哭泣，因为我想她知道，尽管有我的保证，离我再次见到她还需要很长时间。而且我想——我想她会——我想她会希望我保持安全。我想她会希望我能找到一种方法来应对这场危机，而不是屈服于它，而不是被它压垮。
At the end of February, Jiayang did a story for this show about a Chinese man reporting on the virus in Wuhan. In one of the videos this journalist makes, he introduces us to this guy he calls Ah Ming. His father recently died because of coronavirus. Ah Ming talks about being with his father in the last hours of his life, about holding his hand as his heartbeat drops to zero. For Jiayang, it was one of the most emotional moments in this story for obvious reasons.
二月底，贾阳为我们节目做了一个关于一名中国男子在武汉报道病毒的故事。在这位记者制作的视频中，他向我们介绍了这个他称之为阿明的人。他的父亲最近因冠状病毒去世。阿明谈到了在父亲生命的最后几个小时陪伴着他，谈到了当心跳降至零时握着他的手。对贾阳来说，由于显而易见的原因，这是这个故事中最感人的时刻之一。
His story was one that I thought just contained such pain and terror. That was unimaginable to me at the time. And now, I realize that last Tuesday might be the last time I-- I-- last Tuesday might be the last time I will ever-- I mean, that might have been the last time I saw my mother.
他的故事是我认为包含了如此多的痛苦和恐怖的故事。在当时，那对我来说是不可想象的。而现在，我意识到上周二可能是我最后一次——我——上周二可能是我最后一次——我的意思是，那可能是我最后一次见到我母亲。
I can't even get the tenses straight. The grammar doesn't compute in my mind. And I thought that Ah Ming's experience was absolutely the most devastating. And then I think about how lucky Ah Ming was.
我甚至无法准确把握时态。我的脑子里逻辑不通。我原以为阿明的经历绝对是最令人悲痛的。然后我想到阿明是多么幸运。
I know that if my mother contracts COVID-19, she will almost certainly die. And I-- and I also know that-- I also know that, when I get the call from the hospital letting me know that she's been infected, I won't be permitted to go in there. And I can see my mother's window every day. There's a little park that separates my apartment building from my mom's hospital.
我知道如果我母亲感染了 COVID-19，她几乎肯定会死。我——我也知道——我也知道，当我接到医院通知我她已被感染的电话时，我将不被允许进去。我可以每天看到我母亲的窗户。有一个小公园把我的公寓楼和我妈妈的医院隔开了。
And when I stand in the park, I can see her window. I can almost see the orchid that me and my friend brought her a couple of weeks ago. Or at least, I think I can see it. And I think about-- I think about the fact that, when she is dying, if she contracts the virus, those last hours that Ah Ming held his father's hand, maybe-- that maybe I'll be standing in the park, just looking up at her window. Maybe that's the closest-- maybe that's the closest I'll be able to get to her in her last hours.
当我站在公园里时，我能看到她的窗户。我几乎能看到我和朋友几周前带给她的那盆兰花。或者至少，我觉得我能看到它。我想到——我想到这样一个事实，当她垂死时，如果她感染了病毒，阿明握着父亲手的最后几个小时，也许——也许我只会站在公园里，望着她的窗户。也许那是我在最后的时刻能离她最近的地方了。
Emanuele Berry is a producer on our show.
埃曼努埃尔·贝里是我们节目的制作人。
Coming up, a tiny, tiny virus breaks open a jail cell. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来的节目，一种极小极小的病毒冲破了一间牢房。稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, the test-- the coronavirus is here. There are people who, right now, are forced to deal with it. We hear stories of how they face that challenge. We've arrived at act three of our show.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，考验——冠状病毒就在这里。有些人现在被迫面对它。我们听听他们如何面对这一挑战。我们已经到了节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Outbreak Breakout.
第三幕，疫情爆发与释放。
So another way that the coronavirus outbreak has had a huge impact on people's lives-- prisons and jails around the country are starting to release inmates they wouldn't have otherwise, or wouldn't have released as early, anyway, to try to protect prisoners behind bars from getting sick. Correctional institutions, as you can imagine, are Petri dishes of germs and microbes. The latest number that I'm seeing, as I'm recording this, more than 50 inmates at Rikers Island in New York City-- that's just one jail here-- correctional officers there and elsewhere also have the virus now.
所以冠状病毒疫情对人们生活产生巨大影响的另一种方式——全国各地的监狱开始释放那些本来不会释放，或者无论如何都不会这么早释放的囚犯，试图保护囚犯不生病。正如你可以想象的，惩教机构是细菌和微生物的培养皿。据我录制时看到的最新数字，纽约市瑞克斯岛（Rikers Island）——仅仅是这里的一个监狱——就有超过 50 名囚犯确诊，那里的惩教人员和其他地方的工作人员现在也感染了病毒。
So the city is letting 300 inmates go. Right next door, New Jersey ordered 1000 inmates to be released this past week. You're seeing similar decisions like that-- they're not as widespread-- in Ohio, Illinois, Oklahoma, California, and Texas since the crisis hit. In San Francisco, the public defender's office urged the release of, quote, "All people who are immunocompromised or over the age of 60." Producer Sean Cole talked with somebody who made that cut.
所以该市正在释放 300 名囚犯。隔壁的新泽西州上周下令释放 1000 名囚犯。你在俄亥俄州、伊利诺伊州、俄克拉荷马州、加利福尼亚州和德克萨斯州都能看到类似的决定——尽管并不那么普遍。在旧金山，公设辩护人办公室敦促释放所有“免疫力受损或 60 岁以上的人”。制作人肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）采访了一位符合条件的人。
They're really two factors under consideration when figuring out who to release from jail or prison amid the COVID-19 outbreak. One, how severe was the crime? And then, two, how's the person's health? How vulnerable are they? And given these two criteria, one of the best candidates available for release--
在 COVID-19 疫情期间，计算谁该从监狱释放时，实际上有两个因素在考虑。第一，犯罪严重程度如何？第二，个人的健康状况如何？他们有多脆弱？鉴于这两个标准，目前可供释放的最佳候选人之一——
Hello.
你好。
Hi, Terry?
嘿，特里（Terry）吗？
Yes, sir.
是的，先生。
--was Terry Smith. Hi, how are you?
——是特里·史密斯。嘿，你好吗？
--or Ma'am.
——或者是女士。
It's-- [LAUGHS] it's sir.
是——（笑声）是先生。
It's lady?
是女士？
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
It's sir? OK, yeah, because I-- can you still hear me?
是先生吗？好吧，是的，因为我——你还能听到我说话吗？
I can hear you, yeah. Can you hear me?
我能听到你，是的。你能听到我吗？
OK, I'm trying to get some privacy. I'm going to a spot where--
好，我正试图找个私密的地方。我要去一个地方——
I got a hold of Terry at a residential treatment program for veterans called Fresh Start. And they have facilities all over the country. This one, again, is in San Francisco. The court sent him there last week when it became clear that he might be in danger of sitting in a jail cell.
我在一个叫“新鲜开始”（Fresh Start）的退伍军人寄宿治疗项目中联系到了特里。他们在全国各地都有设施。这个，再说一次，在旧金山。当清楚他可能面临坐在牢房里的危险时，法院上周把他送到了那里。
He'd been in the county jail for nearly a year, charged with breaking into a couple of garages, nothing violent. This was just his latest stint on these charges. He's been in and out a few times.
他已经在县监狱待了近一年，被控撬入几间车库，没有暴力行为。这只是他因为这些指控而受到的最新一次关押。他进进出出好几次了。
And at 64, soon to be 65 years old, Terry has a whole pileup of comorbidities that might sound a little overwhelming when I list them. He has a seizure disorder, PTSD from serving in Vietnam, and also being abused when he was a foster kid. He's a recovering heroin addict. And most pressingly right now, Terry suffers from chronic obstructive pulmonary disorder, COPD.
64 岁，快 65 岁了，特里有一堆合并症，当我列出它们时，听起来可能有点令人不知所措。他有癫痫症、在越南服役留下的创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），还有寄养期间被虐待的经历。他是一名正在康复的海洛因成瘾者。而且现在最紧迫的是，特里患有慢性阻塞性肺病，即 COPD。
It's a lung disease that already sent him to the hospital a couple of times, which is why he got so frightened when he heard about the thing that's apparently coming for everybody's lungs. Inmates at San Francisco County jail are allowed to watch TV from 7:00 to 8:00 in the morning. So he just saw it on the news.
这是一种肺部疾病，已经让他几次住进医院，这就是为什么当他听到那种显然是冲着每个人的肺部而来的病毒时，他会如此害怕。旧金山县监狱的囚犯被允许在早上 7 点到 8 点看电视。所以他就在新闻上看到了。
We watch everyday. And we saw it get worse and worse. And people started panicking in the jail. And they don't want to panic in jail.
我们每天都看。我们看到情况越来越糟。监狱里的人开始恐慌。他们不想在监狱里恐慌。
You get a panic in jail, you know what that'd do? Where does that get you? It leads to people, oh, no. We ain't going back to our bunks. We're not-- for three days, we did not eat any meals.
你在监狱里恐慌，你知道那会导致什么吗？那会带你去哪？它导致人们，噢，不。我们不去回我们的铺位了。我们没有——三天了，我们没有吃任何饭。
You didn't eat meals for three days?
你们三天没吃饭了？
For three days.
三天了。
Because you were worried about getting the virus?
因为你们担心感染病毒？
No, well, because so, when they serve the meals, right?
不，好吧，因为，当他们上餐时，对吧？
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
So you have a guy who hands you an empty tray. That's one meal. And there's five people who put something on the tray, the beans, and then they put it into the jello, or the salad. So that's five people, including the guy who puts the tray on there, six people.
所以有一个人递给你一个空托盘。那是一顿饭。有五个人往托盘上放东西，豆子，然后他们把它放进果冻或者沙拉里。所以那是五个人，加上那个递托盘的人，六个人。
And then you've got the guy that takes the tray at the end and stacks it up and put it on a cart. Now we're at seven people, right? They're not wearing masks. They're wearing gloves, but they're not wearing masks.
然后你还有最后取托盘、把它叠起来放到手推车上的人。现在是七个人了，对吧？他们没戴口罩。他们戴着手套，但没戴口罩。
So you think--
所以你认为——
Also--
还有——
You think they're not taking enough precautions if they're in the jail.
你认为如果他们在监狱里，就没有采取足够的预防措施。
No, sir. I mean, they're doing the best they can. But I think they should-- those servers should be wearing masks.
不，先生。我的意思是，他们在尽力。但我认为他们应该——那些送餐员应该戴口罩。
There's no hand sanitizer. So no one wants to eat the food. They're scared. A lot of older guys start trying to teach the young guys, dude, you need to like start washing your bed areas.
没有洗手液。所以没人想吃那些食物。他们很害怕。许多年长的人开始教年轻人，伙计，你们需要像开始清洗你们的床铺区域一样。
You need to start really not touching each other. You stop hand touching. You're not even fully aware of how to, really-- to address this mess.
你们需要真正开始不相互接触。停止手触碰。你们甚至没有完全意识到如何，真正地——处理这团混乱。
Terry has served three years, not in prison, in jail, pre-trial, waiting for his case to be resolved. His lawyer, a guy named Eric Quandt, says that's the amount of time he should serve for the crimes he's accused of. And Eric has been filing motions, trying to get a settlement of some kind, maybe a plea deal. But it kept getting delayed and delayed. And then the virus hit.
特里服刑了三年，不是在监狱，是在羁押室，审前羁押，等待案件解决。他的律师，一个叫埃里克·匡特（Eric Quandt）的人，说这是他为所指控的罪行应该服刑的时间。埃里克一直提交动议，试图达成某种和解，也许是认罪协议。但它一直被推迟又推迟。然后病毒袭来了。
I was scared. And yes, to be honest with you, I was scared. I was scared to get the virus and die up here. Eric saved my life by doing what he did for me. Eric saved my life. And the judge.
我很害怕。是的，老实说，我很害怕。我害怕感染病毒死在这里。埃里克通过他为我所做的拯救了我的生命。埃里克拯救了我的生命。还有法官。
It just seems so crazy that it was a virus that, essentially, came to your rescue.
病毒，本质上是来拯救你的，这看起来太疯狂了。
Yeah, a virus.
是的，病毒。
That was all it took for the criminal justice system to kick into gear, a deadly scourge that's devastating the world. So Terry is no longer behind bars and walks out into a city that's completely on lockdown. Remember, San Francisco was one of the first cities to issue a shelter in place ordinance. He told me he had all these fantasies about what he would do when he was free again-- see his girlfriend. Say hi to his friends. Instead, he's not seeing anyone except the other guys in the facility.
这就是刑事司法系统开始运转所需要的全部，一场蹂躏世界的致命灾难。所以特里不再被关在牢里，走进了完全处于封锁状态的城市。记住，旧金山是最早发布“居家避难”法令的城市之一。他告诉我，他曾幻想自己恢复自由后要做什么——见女朋友。跟朋友打招呼。相反，除了项目里的其他人，他谁也见不到。
My granddaughter's, we-- she's really close to me, real close, OK. I could wait. I'm getting out. I'm going to go get my baby and put her in my arms, you know what I mean?
我的孙女，我们——她和我真的很亲，非常亲，好吧。我能等。我要出去了。我要去把我的宝贝抱进怀里，你知道我的意思吗？
So she says-- she don't understand. Papa, you're out. Why can't you come see me? I want to make sure that, when I come see you, I'm OK to come see you. I got to make sure I'm not bringing her nothing, you know what I mean?
所以她说——她不明白。爸爸，你出来了。为什么你不能来看我？我想确保，当我来看你时，我身体健康。我必须确保我没有给她带去什么东西，你知道我的意思吗？
It's like these two opposite things, being incarcerated and not being incarcerated, inched ever so slightly closer to each other when Terry wasn't looking. His life kind of looks a lot like other people's in America right now, happening indoors, looking at the outside world like it's an exhibit. But listen to how he talks about it.
就像这两种相反的事情，被监禁和没有被监禁，在特里没注意的时候，彼此稍微靠近了一点。他的生活现在看起来很像美国其他人的生活，发生在室内，把外面的世界看作是一个展品。但听听他是怎么说的。
I can look right now-- from the kitchen, I can see the beach. One block from me to the right, one block from me to the right is the park, Golden Gate Park. 10 blocks down, I can see the ocean. I see it every night.
我现在能看到——从厨房里，我能看到海滩。离我右边一个街区，离我右边一个街区就是公园，金门公园。再往下走 10 个街区，我能看到海洋。我每天晚上都能看到。
I watch the sunset. I sat last night and watched the sunset-- red. So want to hear my breakfast? I had an avocado and banana.
我看日落。我昨晚坐着看日落——红色的。所以想听听我的早餐吗？我吃了一个牛油果和一个香蕉。
It's the same words that a lot of us are saying to each other on the phone or Skype or whatever. This is what I'm looking at out my window. This is what I ate. But for Terry, they're a celebration.
这些是我们在电话、Skype 或其他任何工具上对彼此说的同样的话。这是我从窗外看到的。这是我吃的。但对于特里来说，它们是一场庆祝。
Sean is one of the producers of our show.
肖恩是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "BORED" BY MNEK"]
[音乐 - MNEK 的《BORED》]
Act Four, Hello From the Other Side-- OK, so Emanuele Berry, who you heard earlier in the show in act two-- Emanuele used to live in China. And she's been texting back and forth with friends there since January when the virus shut down parts of that country. Now, as American cities are shutting down, a lot of her friends in China are texting her, asking how she's doing. Here's Emanuele.
第四幕，来自另一边的问候——好的，你们在第二幕听到过的埃曼努埃尔·贝里——埃曼努埃尔曾经住在中国。自从一月病毒封锁了那个国家部分地区以来，她一直和那里的朋友发短信联系。现在，随着美国城市陆续封锁，她在中国的许多朋友都在发短信问她怎么样。这是埃曼努埃尔。
The other day, I got this text from China. It said, "A word from your future-- it will get better. Today, we were on the street, and it almost felt normal."
前几天，我收到了这条来自中国的短信。它说：“来自你未来的一句话——情况会变好的。今天，我们在街上，感觉几乎正常了。”
It arrived during a hard week. I was worried about my dad, who's high risk, money, my friends who work in hospitals, my best friend who's supposed to have a kid any day now. I'm constantly thinking about how uncertain each day feels. And I'm craving normal. My friend Rebecca Kanthor, sent it. She lives in Shanghai. And I called her to hear more about this normal.
它是在艰难的一周收到的。我担心我高风险的爸爸，担心钱，担心在医院工作的朋友，担心我最好的朋友，她随时都有可能生孩子。我一直在思考每一天是多么的不确定。我渴望正常。我的朋友丽贝卡·坎索尔（Rebecca Kanthor）发来的。她住在上海。我打电话给她了解更多关于这种“正常”的情况。
Oh, hey. I got to tell my husband to stop--
噢，嘿。我得告诉我丈夫别——
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
He's like in the-- hey, yo. [NON-ENGLISH]. [WHISTLES]
他就像在——嘿，哟。（中文）。（哨声）
Rebecca is American, but she's lived in China for 17 years. She's married to a Chinese man. Her kids go to Chinese schools.
丽贝卡是美国人，但她在中国的居住了 17 年。她嫁给了一个中国男人。她的孩子们上中国的学校。
He's carrying a hunk of frozen meat.
他正扛着一大块冷冻肉。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Wait, for what? Is he cooking?
等等，为了什么？他在做饭吗？
I think he's hungry, and he wants to cut a piece off of it.
我想他饿了，他想切一块下来。
Husband out of the way, we talked. China, of course, has had a much more aggressive response to the virus than anything that's happened in the states so far. They locked down Wuhan, traced contacts, isolated people who are sick, sometimes separating them from their families. The government mandated quarantines.
丈夫走开了，我们交谈起来。当然，中国对病毒的反应比目前在各州发生的任何事情都更加积极。他们封锁了武汉，追踪接触者，隔离病人，有时将他们与家人分离。政府强制实施隔离。
The governor of New York has suggested it might be four to nine months before a stay at home orders are lifted. But in Wuhan, just two months in, the city is set to open up again. And in cities like Beijing and Shanghai, the few new cases being reported are coming from travelers. They've been told to resume life as normal.
纽约州长建议居家避难令解除可能需要四到九个月。但在武汉，仅仅两个月，该市准备重新开放了。而在北京和上海这样的城市，报告的少数新病例来自旅行者。他们被告知要恢复正常生活。
[SIGHS] How are you doing?
[叹气] 你怎么样？
How am I doing? [LAUGHS] I don't know. Like, I think I've accepted that it's going to be tough. But part of me just wants to, like, know that it's going to be OK at the end of it, even if it's going to be so like-- if it's going to be difficult, if that makes sense, you know?
我怎么样？（笑声）我不知道。就像，我想我已经接受了它会很艰难。但我的内心只是想，就像，知道到最后它会没事的，即使它会很——如果它会很困难的话，如果这话听起来有道理的话，你知道吧？
You want to know it's going to be OK in the end?
你想知道到最后一切都会好起来的？
I mean, what was it-- what was it like for you two months ago?
我的意思是，两个月前对你们来说是什么样的？
Yeah, it's-- I mean, it definitely feels different now. I mean, two months ago, it just felt like, yeah, just so uncertain and things changing by the day. Yeah, so just every week was different.
是的，它——我的意思是，现在感觉绝对不同了。我的意思是，两个月前，它就是感觉，是的，就是那么不确定，事情每天都在变。是的，所以每周都不同。
At this point, you're, maybe, on the other side of this-- possibly on the other side of this, like what-- what does that look like?
目前，你可能已经在这一切的另一面了——可能在另一面了，那——那看起来像什么？
Well, OK, so yeah, things are, you know, feeling much better here. I think it just feels like, you know, taking off like a really hot jacket. You know like when you're wearing a winter jacket and, all of a sudden, the weather gets warmer, and you're like, ah, I don't need to be wearing this anymore.
嗯，好吧，所以是的，事情，你知道，在这里感觉好多了。我想这只是感觉，你知道，像脱掉一件非常热的夹克。你知道当你穿着冬装夹克，突然天气变暖了，你会说，啊，我不需要再穿这个了。
You take it off. And you've got short sleeve shirt-- short sleeves on. And you just feel just relaxed.
你把它脱掉。你穿着短袖衬衫——短袖。你就感觉很放松。
Can you take the train now? Like, what are the trains like?
你们现在能坐火车了吗？比如，火车是什么样的？
Yes, I just saw a picture from the train today. And it would-- at the beginning, the trains were-- the subways were still running, I think, the whole way through.
是的，我今天刚看到一张火车的照片。它会——在开始时，火车——地铁仍然在运行，我想，一直到最后。
But back in the beginning, there was like one or two people per car. And now, all the seats-- at least the photo I saw, all the seats were being sat in. But I haven't taken the subway since January.
但在最初的时候，每节车厢里大概有一两个人。而现在，所有的座位——至少我看到的照片，所有的座位都坐满了人。但我从一月份开始就没坐过地铁了。
You haven't? Is there-- is there a reason for that? Or is it just--
你没有？有什么——有什么原因吗？还是只是——
I think I just told myself that that was something that I could control. And I just thought, well, if I can get it there on my electric bike or my bicycle, then I'll go to those places. But if I-- I just--
我想我只是告诉自己那是我可以控制的事情。我只是想，嗯，如果我能骑电动自行车或自行车到达那里，那我就去那些地方。但如果我——我只是——
I stopped taking taxis. And I stopped taking the subway. Even though they're all running, it's just kind of my personal thing that I decided I wasn't going to do.
我不再坐出租车了。我也不再坐地铁了。尽管它们都在运行，但这只是我个人决定的事情，我不打算做。
As I talked to Rebecca and other friends in China, I've noticed this thing. When they talk about things returning to normal, they start describing all these things that aren't normal.
当我和丽贝卡以及其他在中国的朋友交谈时，我注意到了这件事。当他们谈论事情回归正常时，他们开始描述所有不正常的事情。
You know, everyone's still wearing a mask.
你知道，每个人仍然戴着口罩。
Here, we're told not to wear a mask. In some cities in China, masks are mandatory.
这里，我们被告知不要戴口罩。在中国的一些城市，口罩是强制性的。
Or like I saw-- like the other day, I saw someone taking a selfie. And then, like, halfway through the selfie, they were like, oh, shoot. I'm still wearing my mask. So they to remember, take it off, and then take the selfie again.
或者就像我看到——就像前几天，我看到有人在自拍。然后，就像，自拍拍了一半，他们就像，噢，该死。我还在戴着口罩。所以他们得记住，脱下它，然后再拍一次自拍。
What-- does that mask-- does it sort of feel like this reminder to you that it's like, oh, this isn't normal?
那——那个口罩——它是否感觉像是在提醒你，就像，噢，这不正常？
Yeah, yeah, it's kind of like-- because actually the government said you can take off your masks. They said-- you know, they had a press conference. And the government official took their mask off and was like, you can take your masks off. You only need them when you go into certain public areas. But in reality, most people are still wearing them.
是的，是的，它有点像——因为实际上政府说你们可以脱下口罩了。他们说——你知道，他们召开了新闻发布会。政府官员摘下口罩说，你们可以脱掉口罩了。你们只需要在进入某些公共区域时才需要它们。但在现实中，大多数人仍然戴着它们。
And it's not just that people are still wearing masks. Temperature taking is now everywhere.
而且不仅仅是人们仍然戴着口罩。测体温现在到处都是。
So when you go into any public space and also when you enter any housing compound, like an apartment complex, there's someone at the gate with a little body sensor thermometer. And they put it up to your head, or they put it on your wrist, and take your temperature.
所以当你进入任何公共空间，以及当你进入任何住宅区，比如公寓大楼时，门口有人拿着一个小身体传感器温度计。他们把它贴到你的头上，或者把它放到你的手腕上，测量你的体温。
The newest thing for Rebecca to get used to has been this QR code system. It basically sorts people. Should you be quarantined or not? It's a little unclear how people are being sorted into these categories.
丽贝卡需要习惯的最新事物是这个二维码系统。它基本上将人们分类。你应该被隔离吗？人们是如何被分类到这些类别中还不是很清楚。
But it involves people's locations being tracked through their cell phone. If you've recently visited a hospital, been around a sick person, bought a train or a plane ticket, it's being monitored. The code is like an admission ticket to do anything in the city.
但它涉及人们的位置通过手机进行追踪。如果你最近访问过医院，在病人身边待过，买过火车票或飞机票，它都在被监控。二维码就像在城市做任何事情的入场券。
I went to visit a friend at their apartment complex. And I had to-- first of all, I had to register my name, phone number, passport number. And then I also had to show them on my phone a-- like a QR code, like a little square code that shows that I've been in Shanghai for the past 14 days. So I get a green code.
我去参观朋友的公寓大楼。我不得不——首先，我必须登记我的姓名、电话号码、护照号码。然后我还必须在我的手机上出示一个——就像一个二维码，就像一个小方块代码，显示我在过去 14 天里一直待在上海。所以我得到了一个绿色代码。
And you know, the only way they can find that out is they have my phone records and like my GPS coordinates or whatever. I don't know how they find it. But that's not something that-- I don't know. Is that possible in the US?
而且你知道，他们能找到这一点的唯一方法就是他们有我的电话记录和我之类 GPS 坐标。我不知道他们是怎么找到的。但那不是——我不知道。这在美国可能吗？
I don't-- I don't think-- I don't think so. [LAUGHS]
我——我不认为——我不认为如此。（笑声）
Right, now, that offers-- that gives me-- that makes me feel like I have a sense of security, to be honest, because I look at it and I say, oh, well, I've been here for the past 14 days. I'm in the safe zone. You know, and if you go elsewhere, if you, maybe, go to another city or you travel abroad and you come back, then you're in a yellow zone or a red zone.
没错，现在，那提供——那给予我——那让我觉得我有了一种安全感，说实话，因为我看着它说，噢，好吧，我在过去 14 天里一直待在这里。我在安全区。你知道，如果你去别处，如果你可能去另一个城市，或者你出国旅行又回来，那么你就在黄色区域或红色区域了。
To play the game of basketball, you need a QR code. And then when you get to the park, a volunteer takes your temperature before letting you in.
要打篮球，你需要一个二维码。当你到达公园时，志愿者在让你进去之前会先测体温。
They do limit the numbers of people going into the park across the street from my house. But there's just-- it's always lots of people there now. But I think they still-- I do not think they have let the ladies do their square dancing at night. I think that is not back to normal.
他们确实限制了进入我家对面公园的人数。但那里只是——现在总是很多人。但我认为他们仍然——我不认为他们让女士们晚上跳广场舞了。我想那还没恢复正常。
So usually, at nighttime, like around 7:00 PM in all the parks, you'll have like older women and older men doing dance routines, line dancing routines. And that has stopped. And I don't think it's come back.
所以通常在晚上，比如晚上 7 点，在所有的公园里，会有像老太太和老大爷跳舞蹈套路，排舞套路。而那已经停止了。我想它还没回来。
Rebecca says they discourage it because the crowds would be too much. I doubt that our future in the US looks anything like what Rebecca is describing. But everything feels so chaotic here. And the idea that eventually that feeling stops, you get used to the new normal, I can take comfort in that.
丽贝卡说他们不鼓励它，因为人群会太多。我怀疑我们在美国的未来是否看起来像丽贝卡描述的那样。但这里的一切感觉如此混乱。而那种感觉最终会停止的想法，你习惯了新常态，我能从中得到安慰。
Emanuele Berry.
埃曼努埃尔·贝里。
[MUSIC - "MIAMI, 2017" BY BILLY JOEL]
[音乐 - 比利·乔尔（Billy Joel）的《MIAMI, 2017》]
Our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis and Nadia Reiman. The people put together today's show from their own homes-- Bim Adewunmi, Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Noor Gill, Damien Graef, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katharine Rae Mondo, Ben Phelan, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetela, and Matt Tierney.
我们今天的节目由达纳·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）和纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）制作。大家都是在自己家里把今天的节目拼凑起来的——比姆·阿德温米（Bim Adewunmi）、埃曼努埃尔·贝里、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔、努尔·吉尔（Noor Gill）、达米恩·格拉夫（Damien Graef）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、米奇·米克、莉娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katharine Rae Mondo）、本·费伦（Ben Phelan）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威特拉（Christopher Swetela）和马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。
Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Clara Amfo, Patty Lyons, and everybody at Meals on Wheels in Savannah, Georgia, James Dominick Jr, Sammy Chase, Sam Braun, Vicky Ibarra, Daniel Harris, Peter McNally, George, Jamie Lowe, Adnan Khan, Alex, Kim Sue, Chuck Leong, Christina Peña, and Zelu Goa.
我们的管理编辑是黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的执行编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。今天特别感谢克拉拉·阿姆福（Clara Amfo）、帕蒂·莱昂斯（Patty Lyons）以及佐治亚州萨凡纳“送餐上门”（Meals on Wheels）的所有人、詹姆斯·多米尼克（James Dominick Jr）、萨米·蔡斯（Sammy Chase）、萨姆·布劳恩（Sam Braun）、维姬·伊巴拉（Vicky Ibarra）、丹尼尔·哈里斯（Daniel Harris）、彼得·麦克纳利（Peter McNally）、乔治、杰米·洛（Jamie Lowe）、阿德南·汗（Adnan Khan）、亚历克斯、金·苏（Kim Sue）、查克·梁（Chuck Leong）、克里斯蒂娜·佩尼亚（Christina Peña）和泽鲁·戈阿（Zelu Goa）。
Our website, where, to pass the time in lockdowns in your own home, you can stream our archive of nearly 700 episodes for absolutely free, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，在您家中的封锁期间为了打发时间，您可以完全免费地流媒体播放我们近 700 集的档案，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》通过 PRX（公共无线电交换）传递给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, when I was in quarantine last week, he called me every single day to make sure I was OK. But I don't know, I don't think that he had the right list of symptoms. He kept asking me--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，当我上周被隔离时，他每天都给我打电话确认我是否还好。但我不知道，我不认为他有正确的症状列表。他一直问我——
Oh, is your butt hurting?
噢，你的臀部在痛吗？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。